hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of project Euler 100 in which
we're going over the problems in the
project Euler series I think we should
call it series right so far we did
problems from 1 to 23 and 25 last time
we had some issues figuring out how to
solve problem 24 which is a bummer but
well I looked up some resources and
hopefully today we can solve that and
move on to the next month
hello Laurent and welcome whoops I have
drawn over later yeah I did I did have
to run on less than T all right if you
are in the chat if you support the free
code camp community and become a
subscriber on YouTube then you will be
able to chat and help me figure out the
solutions here because some of them will
be pretty tough I've looked at the next
one 26 and they're not getting easier
that they could tell I don't know how
long we will be able to go they're
getting very mad heavy so yeah we'll see
them now for the problem 24 let's go
over again what we had to do and then
eventually solve it hopefully this time
we can like so lexicographic permutation
this is a hard word to pronounce a
permutation is an ordered arrangement of
objects for example three one two four
is one possible permutation of the
digits 1 2 3 & 4
if all of the preparations are listed
numerically or alphabetically we call it
lexicographic order and the
lexicographic permutations of 0 1 & 2
are these right you can see there go in
order and what we have to do we need to
see what is the nth lexicographic
permutation of the digits 0 1 2 3 4 up
to 9 so for that I think we need to get
all the permutations
order and that get the end one right
okay now last time we looked at one
algorithm which well I it's pretty much
the same algorithm we have here
I found this on Quora thanks to Daniel
Shipman
he solved this using this algorithm so I
took a pic and I think I know now how to
do it so basically we have four steps
let's first create that array which will
be the let's see so we could have an
array of arrays
or we could have an array of strings I'm
thinking which one should be better
let's start with an array of arrays so
maybe let's see permutations and first
one will be 0 1 2 3 let's start with the
smaller one and see that we have it
correct and afterwards
I don't like this for some reason my
raver that's Hartley
oops I ran it maybe have initial and
let's have it as a string
I'm think this should okay let's look at
the algorithm now so it's all about the
indexes inside that array as you can see
here we have an array of arrays so
inside this array we have indexes index
0 1 2 now they are the same as the
numbers we have in the array but they
will change so look at what this says
find the largest X such that P of X is
less than P of X plus 1 if there are no
such X then P is the last permutation so
we go inside the array and we go over
all of them up to the last one and we
check is this index P of X is this
number let's see less than the next one
if it is then we save the index and we
go that way does it make sense and I
guess it will do when we write a code
then the next step will be to find the
largest Y so the index such that P of X
is less than P of Y then we swap the two
elements inside the array and then we
reverse from P of X plus 1 up to the end
of the array so let's copy this and have
it here so we don't change the tab that
match so this is 1 then this is 2 this
is 3 and this is 4 ok so let's do that
what we want to do
should we have DeRay initially then push
it somewhere I'm thinking
okay or we could go over the string
yeah let's start with initial to be a
string actually zero one two and then
permutations and we can even put them
inside function here okay
yeah I didn't check can you hear me well
can you see everything well hopefully
okay so we don't have any permutations
now
let's see how long do we want to do this
this is the thing which will stop it
right
so we get a wild yeah it can do wild my
freaking cam platform well complain
about this I think there we can even
find out how many permutations there
might be and we can just loop until we
have all the permutations that could be
one solution to avoid wild through
but yeah let's look for this now okay so
one find the largest X such that P of X
less than P of X plus one so for that we
need a loop I 0 I less than initial I
initial this will be changed
yeah so let's call it current or array
because we're going to work on this
array and we're going to swap elements
inside it and then we're going to push
them here guess we can put the first one
and then I'm going to push the next ones
all right let's see how this goes
so array that flanked minus one so we
don't want to go up to this so we want
to check this with this and then this
one with the last one I plus plus if so
we have here find the largest X such
that P of X less than P of X plus one
if array of I is less than array of I
plus 1 then we want to store this index
so let's call it with let let's call it
X and B minus 1 by default as if we
don't find it we will break out of the
loop that's the base condition if there
is no such X then P is the last
fermentation ok and here so if we find
this then X will be Y right so it will
be the current let's see so find a large
sector that yeah so we need that now
this is the base so the let's call it
the break break condition step one or
let's just put one here this will be the
break
so if X is minus one so we don't find
here then we just want to break out of
the of the while loop all right if not
then we want to go to the step two and
here we need to find the largest Y such
that P of X less than P of Y so again we
need Y which will be minus one for left
I is less than zero I I 0 I less than
array that length I plus plus we can go
up to the end of the right now so now if
array of I is less than array of y
to store that right
yeah so Y will be high let's see so X is
y yeah well X is I whites hi
good
so that should be doing that part and
weapon to disappear and for the well the
next one we want for three we want to
swap the two elements now swapping
elements
for that if we swap the elements inside
this array well first the nudes accounts
so we can't really manipulate this array
so for that let's create a new array so
that new array which will be a copy of
the old array right so we copy
everything is inside here
okay now issue is that I will still need
this new array in the next loop so let's
just work with this one then we're going
to change this array on here okay so we
want to swap to them how we're going to
swap we need temporary file the
temporary variable to store one of the
items
so maybe array index X then array index
X will be array index Y and array index
Y will be array will be tapped right so
we store X array index X in the temp and
we use it then later we swap the two
elements here
yeah let me write something here find
largest largest X large X and next one
is fine largest why find largest why
okay and then we swap and at the end we
want to reverse this array from X plus 1
up to the end so how we're going to do
that
reverse array
let's see so we go up to that element
would keep it like that then we take the
rest of the array and we reverse it and
put it back right so array will be
arrey slice from zero to X
we want to add this oaken cat or we
could do something like well spread it
inside this new array array dot slice X
plus one and reverse so we take the
first half we add it inside new array
and then the second half from X plus one
we reverse and then we add it in this
array and now hopefully if we did it
right let's add it to the permutations
array so permutations that push the
array which will basically be the new
array in the loop and let's just return
the permutation here so we can see them
if we cancel that vlog
all right let's see zero undefined 2
minus 1 1
okay that's not good what's happening
here
so permutations and then we push their
way is there something
counsel that loud permutations
okay that's good I think
[Music]
we're messing with the array and doesn't
like it
all right facts yeah but then
Oh
so when we put here to Ray
and we change the array
you
[Music]
also change its place inside this array
so let's then do something else let's
just join this array I have a string and
whenever we push with two just join
again
are
that's that's a start you can see that
we kind of have the pattern we just miss
something let's see so slice from 0 to X
alright and slice from X plus 1
and then reverse
let's see these two values so we can see
exactly what's happening so yes and
console o'clock this any obviously
that's not - dad
I'll put this here actually
so 0-2
oops let's
0 & 2 mmm that's not what we want X
minus 1
so in this instance I think so we want
to swap these two
shouldn't
ah
this shouldn't be reversed because it's
the last one let's see do we have here
an example suppose P is this number that
represented file starting at the end we
see for greater than to the native
waited up for the nine greater than
eight and finally three less than nine
hence our X is five zero one two three
four
zero one two three four five
why is five zero one oh one two three
four five it's one it's not zero based
I'll do that's why okay
then starting from X plus one we can see
that
3908
three less than four but really created
until the last value that was still
greater than three was four and its
index was I eight one two three four
five six seven eight okay so it's one
the first slice would just reverse
nothing because one item right yeah and
we want that
one item it shouldn't be reversed
swapping py we obtained so we should
swap three with four yeah that's what it
does for three okay
by reversing the part from X plus 1/2
then we're going to resolve the
permutation so it should swap these yeah
I got write logic so this will pose X
and we need to swap all these now maybe
the slice does here's something we don't
want
undefined undefined
first half second half
zero to undefined all right so some
things going on there we have undefined
at least now we have the correct length
I guess
console that plug let's see the array we
have an undefined there which is not
good
zero undefined 2 minus 1 1 what is this
let's break after one loop
you
that's definitely not what we want so X
is minus one we go from 1 up 2 from 0 up
to the right then I minus 1
and that's that let's see cuz of that
log X logging here X is 1 okay good now
why should be 2 so let's see console
that log why this should be 2
all right that works on the swap the
swap is maybe doing something tricky
here
array of x-ray
also the clock temporary okay
temporary is an array of one yeah yet
then cancel the vlog array of X
we're a of X is undefined
why
arrey of Y is one
gets from tap but why it's ray of X
undefined
one and then afterwards
undefined why what's array of why okay
array of why
very wise and find
you
also the fog array of y:real why I think
here is undefined - but why why is 2 y
is minus 1 ok ok ok
oh I think I know
did console.log why
and I can select the value it should be
that's where didn't see all right so
it's minus one so here we have an issue
let's go with that look so find the
largest Y such that P of X less than P
of Y so P of X
[Music]
yeah so if P of X less than R a of i-10
that's alright cut so that was the case
we used the wrong indexes here my bad so
now it should let me remove all these
consoles oops
okay maybe it's the slice now it's wrong
we should have let see console that lava
right here should be the correct yeah
okay good good good good if we remove
the break
goody-goody almost so then this breaks
Americans console that log array again
all right so
zero-one
let me see these again what I'm doing
here
slice and the reverse and everything and
let's see this before we actually do it
so many console logs please break here
so this is the array this is slice 0 X 0
X should be that included 0 2 and then
the end would be dead okay so that's and
slice goes up to up to but not included
so then we go from 0 to X plus 1 which
is not included so gets only up to X and
then from X plus 1 we go up to the end
if you don't specify the second one and
goes to the end ok so now this should
work
let me move the console logs here
you'll have one console.log here and one
here oh that works alright finally
finally finally finally finally after
years of work a week we got it so now it
should work with zero one two three
should work with zero one two three four
finally thank you let's see who wrote
this although as so we saw this
algorithm less than but I didn't know
exactly how to take it thank you Michael
and thank you daniel shipment for
explaining it much better
oh he kinda did - think I am doing
failed bunch of times and then
eventually he got it right
alright good so this is it now what we
want to do is to put five six seven
eight nine let's not
console.log so witness not turn the
permutations but rather permutations
all right that will break let me remove
this
and it's long so it might break s of
permutations of n right we are given the
N and we want that
although we can do one thing when the
permutations has the length M then we
can stop let's see will this work
properly undefined
that's one way
rotations are nice yeah let's see will
this be too much
test timed out oops
tests timed out tests timed out
if this doesn't work then well
I mean it could should work we just need
more time it is an M factorial
it's just then
yes of this let's just do if
permutations that length is equal equals
2n
right and we just do permutations of n o
if then break
they should be faster it doesn't go up
to the end should return number she
returned oh I think it works we just
returned our string because we have an
array of strings not the number
you
hey I won't argue
should return should
to return return
to get a number so something is still
wrong here
all right let's do what we did last time
and run this on directing this code so
that we can see exactly what's happening
although it will take some time so
permutations
let's open this with vs code
and the browser might be
and their thing you might fail although
it might tempt I'm not okay
fermentations I'll just scrape the chess
paste this in and
[Music]
yeah from tier seven Oh equals n plus
one because we want from days of of n
and permutations of n will be undefined
right because it's zero based so here up
to n plus one
you
no no that's what's happening
we want to see yeah that when it is
returned the number and for 909 we
should get it oh yeah so it worked all
right I didn't have to run it again that
was the issue so we were we wanted
permutations of n but we only went up to
permutations n minus one because it's
zero based all right good what we could
put the link here from chora in case
someone wants to take a big okay run the
tests again
it's slow but eventually it works we
don't need this anymore so we can close
it
so
is has some issues don't let the curve
yeah that's what I want once it works
now it might take timeout sometimes
depending on
yeah let's save these quickly submit and
by go to the next one okay so we did
this baby thank you in the name of
freaky camp for becoming a supporter now
you can join chat and help us
so all this we finished 25% of 100 I
honestly don't know how far I could
personally go because they're getting
met heavy really really met heavy you'll
see the next one I took a look and
like this area but it seems expensive
yeah
you
all right so break water break yeah look
at this and can't even really this is
another map have you won what I'm going
to do from now on is if I get stuck for
a long time I'm just going to go to the
next one maybe we can solve it I don't
know if you were in the previous stream
but this is what happens so we worked
like an hour for this one we couldn't do
it and then we solve this in like five
minutes so yeah we might skip a few if
we don't know we can research and find
up ways to do it and we can come back
later and solve it or yeah I honestly
don't know if I can finish all the 100
project if it can then we're going to do
something simpler maybe code words or
other coding challenges depends on what
you want sorry I feel free to let me
know okay problem 26 Ritchie Procol
cycles hopefully I pronounced this right
a unit fraction contains one in the
numerator the decimal representation of
the unit fractions with denominators two
to ten are given so
days when you divide one to two we'll
get that what's up pop become a member
just for you oh thank you you're great
yeah we're solving these challenges or
at least we're trying alright okay so we
get all of this now the parentheses
means that that number will repeat the
infinite
so yeah it's a recurring cycle it can be
seen as one over seven has a six digit
recurring cycle this one now what we
need to do and I honestly don't think I
know I don't think you know I don't know
find the value of D less than n so we
get and here we need to go over all the
numbers for which 1 over D contains the
longest recurring cycle in its decimal
fraction part so in this case the
longest recurring cycle is 1 over 7
right right because it has 6 digits
yeah it looks like fun
although how we're going to do this so
basically we need to do the division 1
over D while going over the numbers so
let's do that let I will be to I less
than n I plus plus and here we need to
do the division so result will be I
weight 1 over I or I guess let's call it
D so then it will be easier to see so D
we start with 2 and we go over that we
get the result
hairpin welcome so we get the result and
now we should look inside the digits and
see
how many of recurring digits we have
any ideas in the chat Lauren leave it
upon anyone
let's get the result let's see what we
have here
all right so
we get something like this which we
might be able to use or not
how we're going to find out
click the result into an array and then
irate at full length
I don't know
and long division
so I keep dividing but then how
have a cycle
so here we go three then with zero then
we see three again we can kind of
check these three again so this is the
thing how can we find out when we have
a recurring cycle
look at this 285 whoop seven one four
two eight five seven one four you can
kind of see visually but for something
like this
the same number again then the division
will give the same result so they cannot
repeat
okay okay something something I see
something there
again look at this here we have the 515
decks we have that three which will
repeat
and you know what about
this where it will repeat
infinite loop we can't find something to
be repeated
you can see this is repeating one seven
eight five seven one four two eight five
you
eight five seven one four two eight five
seven one four two these styles here
yeah I don't know
sick sick sick sick sick sick so and
over
yeah I don't know exactly
I can find out
it can kind of get the digits and maybe
using the vision we
get it
you
yeah I don't know maybe we should
research this and
then come back late yeah let's see what
about the next one
26
oh this is Tennessee's if you do the
long division you multiply by 10 and
then and that is your new numerator yeah
but when we need to multiply by the the
length of the number
[Music]
so if we have five six seven then we
multiply so we get a thousand we divide
it in a thousand and
- Matti let's go to the next one
quadratic primes this doesn't look well
night
[Music]
if the numerator repeats then you are in
elope
when do you know it repeat
Oh
[Music]
quadratic Prime's Euler discovered the
remarkable quadratic formula
and squared plus an plus 41 it returns
out that the formula will produce 40
primes for the consecutive integer
values between 0 & 39
however when n is 40
is divisible 41 and certain one yeah
okay so that doesn't work the incredible
formula was discovered which produce 80
primes for the consecutive values the
product of the coefficients
- 79 and yeah so methi consider
quadratics of the form n square plus a n
plus B where modulus of n that's the
range and be less than I bet oiler will
be terrible parties what else depends on
the party it might be a cutting party so
then it won't be a genius or a math
party
and modest modulus yeah good find the
product of the coefficients a and B for
the quadratic expression that produces
the maximum number of prime for
consecutive values of n starting with N
equals zero
oh boy
this is not
easy again
one second
you
okay
[Music]
I might expire diagonals
starting with the
want to move into the right
one two three so we kind of did
something like this
what is the sum of the numbers of
diagonals
oh so this should be doable
finally finally some something doable
what I see here
is actually not that that so you can see
there is a pattern so from in the inner
circle we get one three five seven nine
then we get plus 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 4
they are all doable yeah but not by
spirit what is the sum of the numbers on
the diagonals in an N by n spiral formed
in the same way and by a what
till 100 well so yeah we definitely
won't have to draw the well
how do you call it the matrix
these took you two days
have it have video rates far you you did
all of them
oh that's pretty good if you did then
pitch yeah so I kind of see a pattern
starts with one the next one are two
bigger the next one are four bigger the
next ones are probably six bigger so for
that they want to just draw well write
it 21 22 23 24
25 you got that one the one you
mentioned zero seven zero eight zero
nine ten nineteen six one two
11:18 five or three twelve whoa eighteen
18 17 16 15 14 13 okay so what's next
like that okay so here we go 26 27 28 29
thirty
let me put some boilerplate here 31 32
33 that for I just want to write them
down so that we can probably find a
pattern 38 39 for time I mean visually
and then we can kind of create some kind
of formula 42 43 44 45 46 7 8 & 9 one
thing you can notice that are they're
all odd numbers okay so as I said these
ones are like double plus 2 plus 2 plus
2 plus 2 then plus 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus
4 and if I'm right hopefully the next
one should be plus 6 yeah 25 plus 6 plus
6 plus 6 plus 6 all right so then this
is not that hard
we start with 1 we add 2 4 times with 4
4 then and we just increase the number
we adding by 2
see that should be I don't have the same
where this Zoey's and and the previous
one was so hard but maybe for some
people it's the other way around
all right so let's some will be one let
add addition this will be the number one
tread and for let's see let 0 I less
than n I plus plus so if n is 1 we don't
add and it's one we have 1 we have we
start with sorry I is zero we don't want
to do that with Annies
right I'm losing my train of thoughts
now so if n is one we yeah I can't get
now if n is two we want to start doing
the sum plus equals ad like that
and we want to do it four times I guess
we could do J equals zero J less than
four J plus plus and we do that and here
at the end we just do ad plus equals two
turn the sir
as fast cancel that plug
that doesn't seem to work
what is the sum of the numbers on the
diagonals
so what happened
what time is let's see so for 101
Oh
so the sum is not that number it's the
sum plus the addition so we start with
one
and then we add 1 plus so some will be
ok let me think again so the next number
will be 3 so we increased some ok ok
let's keep track of the current number
number will be 1 the some old number and
here the number will be plus equals E
and then the sum will be plus equals
very close
so now it's one then is three then is
five seven and nine right
let's check cancel that log
well first let me just this so we don't
get a lot consular lock number okay if
we do for three we get three five seven
nine twenty five
25
why
for
Oh Oh okay 25 is there okay
he's just the return of the Sun here so
the Sun is dead all right so now yeah my
bad my bad
so the next numbers let's see 3 5 7 9 13
17 21 25 the next ones will be
31 37 43 49 cyborgs should start from 1
now it is apparently works maybe I just
don't need to
go up to n
okay so it can be verified that as some
of the numbers on the diagonals is 101
yeah so we have N equals three
ok 4 4 will be one yeah
we need to go up to n plus one or
inconclusive
and now if we do three here we should
get 101 yes I was going one less than we
should have so now this should work we
don't need to cancel this we get 101 for
101 we should get that number
that's yes now currently we're failing
you
what is the sum of numbers and diagrams
in an N and M spiral formed
the second
starting with the number one and moving
to the right in a clockwise direction
five by five spiral is formed but we're
not then maybe missing the last round
yeah it was initially but wait so this
is not three by three this is five by
five
so
we're missing here the ends
because for an N of went five by five we
get this big number but actually we
should only get 101 so maybe minus one
we'll work now what for
get 10 you get that
three by three so this doesn't feel like
being right we're going way further
mmm
and divided by two
plus one I really don't know don't ask
me why today
yeah it works if n is three and you
start with I equals two then you have
only one look yeah
[Music]
you know there are two questions the
programmer is asking it would it doesn't
work
why and then the second one is it works
why so yeah I figured something
somewhere so basically here we have a
5x5 but we only increase one two times
right
yeah say so we have a 5x5 grade but this
goes one and two so then we have
five divided by two which is two point
five plus one is three point five so we
go twice because we all have one in the
ice two and then goes for is three
yeah I the reason why I used / - in my
mind I think so I noticed that it's kind
of half so I did / - and then I saw that
this number is just a bit smaller than
this one and then oh well why not plus
one and that worked
[Laughter]
yeah
life of a programmer
yeah let's download it this is
this is one of a kind
let's go to the next one there are so
many numbers here again let's see
consider so distinct powers consider all
all integers combination of a B for to
the less than equals a left includes
five so a between two and five P between
two and five dot a dot these ^ to the
power three power four or five if there
then sorry so if they are then placed in
numerical order with any repeats removed
we get the following sequence of 15
distinct herbs
how many distinct terms are in a
sequence generated by a ^ B
for to less than so a between two N and
B root into a net
okay
so basically be
over this loop twice
so from I or we could just a a from 2 to
n be from 2 to n we get a to the power
of B we get the numbers and then remove
the duplicates and we check how many
distinct numbers there right I think so
let a let's use a this time to a less
than equals the end a plus plus 4 let B
equals to B s equals death and coups and
B plus plus and then we need to do and a
result will be mapped up how a ^ b
you
I'm thinking now we need to put them in
an array we could do const array like
that and do array that push result and
then well we need to filter out the
duplicates but let's see what we get
here also that flog that we get all
these numbers look at that
go go go go so many numbers
but you want
not double gate number so we could
convert this to an object and do object
of res object of rest to be true and
then here we have object which you'll
have all the values and they will be
unique so we can just do object that
keys of object that white
that works
right so we have all the distinct
numbers we put them in the subject and
at the end we get the keys the length of
the keys
alright get this wasn't that part
thinking to the ones we skipped don't
like that we skipped em but there or so
is it there so hard this was easy
yeah by the way if you're watching and
did you enjoy what you're saying and you
want to support me cut camp if you learn
don't freak out camp feel free to donate
support the nonprofit organization and
help others learn how to code for free
alright digit and powers surprisingly
there are only three numbers that can be
written as the sum of four powers of
their digit oh that's interesting so if
you get a digit to the power of four
you get that as one over four is then is
not a sum it is oh it's not the sound so
it's not included all right the sum of
these numbers is that okay find the sum
of all the numbers that can be written
as the sum of n powers of their digits
but
days so all the numbers I mean what's
the limit all the numbers like a
gazillion do we need to go up to this
zillion
how do we check for that
what's this top the breaking point
I mean you can see that the power of
four you can go up to 9000
you
any idea so we could simply just well
take a number break digits
raise them to the power of n and do the
sum so that's easy but then what's the
stuff so where do we stop how many
numbers do we check
there must be a way
we know that this is the last number
you
[Music]
you
there are only three numbers that can be
written as a sum of fourth powers of
their digit digit
these numbers that find the sum of all
the numbers that can be written as the
sum of em powers of their digits
if they would say
find the sum of the all the numbers from
up to n that can be written then that
would have been yeah easy
you
yeah C sub 1 is too easy the next one is
not too easy
have no idea where to look what to think
to be the stop condition I mean do I go
up to 10,000 do I go up to 100,000
how can we find out there are no more
I mean yeah this is surprising that it's
only three because after nine here we go
you can go 1-0 when something but yeah
but after only three I'll trust them but
how do they know did they check like all
the numbers in the universe
you
you
no idea honestly don't have any idea how
to do that I mean only for passing the
test I can kind of see that this goes up
to probably 100,000 because we have a
sum of numbers which go up too which
will result in 443,000 right
that won't be a good solution
maybe brute force first yeah and have a
like Burt stop
you
so we have zero look at this
we have zero numbers which
there DG ^ to equal the number
zero numbers
so then basically
when you finish the vailable yeah that
old timer
thank you for becoming the supporter in
the name of Wicca camp thank you very
much for supporting the channel and
another nonprofit organization
yeah let's go to the next one at the end
we're going to have like a lot of empty
spots here coin sums
this looks like a fun thing
Koen sums in england the currencies made
up of pound and pence and there are
eight coins in general circulation 110:1
pens to pen isn't finished
I don't know in England coins all right
it is possible to make two dollars in
the following way
one pound one times fifty pence
all right how how many different ways
can n pens be made using any number of
points
that does this feel like permutations
again
how many different ways
this is definitely an algorithm
somewhere
I mean you can do okay first you can do
it by having so n is 50 right you can do
it by having 51 then that's I don't know
how to pronounce that sorry and then you
can do it by having 48 of one and one of
two then you can have it 46 of one and
two of to say where I'm going with this
then you can have it 45 of one and 105
so that's a gazillion this is definitely
an algorithm and unfortunately I don't
know it so I won't spend a lot of time
to to try to get it because I'd have no
idea these are getting harder and harder
so I don't know
I could start to learn about algorithms
more in depth but then
I need to learn them in a wait so that I
could teach it
yeah it's come becoming complicated or
we could switch we can put project order
and pause it's very much happy this is
why it's getting harder but I guess
that's the idea
then digital products we shall say that
an end digit number is pandigital if it
makes up if it makes use of all the
digits 1 to n exactly once for example
the five digit number 1 5 2 3 4 is 1
through 5 and digital the product 7 2 5
4 in his unit is unusual as the identity
3 9 times 1 8 6 equals the number
contains multiple oh boy so fancy words
words containing multiplicand
multiplicand multiplied and product is 1
2 9 so you basically have all the
numbers
the sum of all products whose day things
can be written as one through nine
pen digital hint some products can be
obtained in more than one way so be sure
to own included ones in your son
okay
yeah
we kind of hit and here
Laurent what do you think are they
getting harder and harder
so we
we can go over the numbers and find prod
products
find the sum of all products whose
multiple multiplicand the multiplier
product that it can be written as one
through nine and we have it here so we
basically we can just return that and
with that don't do this this is just for
fun then this you should fit you should
solve it
[Music]
Guga let's learn together
know where to start
mazie clay
we can get a number which does it have
similar digits and then get two more
numbers all of those digits should be
available from one to nine and then
somehow the multiplication of those
numbers should end up to the third
number
all right I don't know
keep trying
he's this all we could do
digit cancelling fraction digit
factorials circular primes double bass
palindromes strong capable primes
numbers numbers numbers powers primes
was it the same at the beginning number
number yeah that was with numbers but it
was like simple
32 is hard yeah
aren't they all everything's hard if you
don't know what to do let's say that x1
fractions
again we need to find out everything
[Music]
exactly for non-trivial examples
okay I think I hit my and here digit
factorials one four five is a curious
number as one factorial 5 4 factorial 5
factorial is the number and the numbers
and the sum of the numbers which are
equal to sum of the factorial of the
digits
you
find the numbers and the sum of the
numbers which are equal to the sum of
the factors so again going over all the
numbers I mean we can see here that we
have only two numbers two curious
numbers
what
I could just do it like go up to 100,000
right do that find factorials
oh let me check something project Euler
dotnet I want to see what what they want
in this prize what's D requirements for
[Music]
where is it 34
find the server sorry finally some of
our numbers which are equal to Samuel
factorial of their digit
same problem which we had before yeah
all right I think I'm going to stop here
unfortunately and yeah I don't want to
keep you all here to see me not know how
to do this and I'm going to look all of
them see if we could find if we could
solve them or other were other problems
and if not we're going to start in
another series yeah they are getting
harder but oh well we did 27 so let's
start
someone with more knowledge of
algorithms should be able to do more so
I encourage you to try and you can rub
it on my nose think that's the same
right and yeah
all right
you
yeah seem to discard thinker for doing
sorry for yeah I don't want to just keep
you here watching me fail that art I
mean you won't learn much so I will look
at them and when I found solutions the
way I could probably explain we're going
to get back and continue this thank you
for watching thank you for being part I
think this was the fifth or the sixth so
we had a good run maybe one day we can
continue but we need to learn so let's
that NSE you the next step
bye